- NO REASON
TO BE NERVOUS.
I'M THE ONE WHO'S ABOUT
TO PROPOSE TO MY GIRLFRIEND.
- WHAT?
- A LIFELONG COMMITMENT.
- YOU'RE JOKING, RIGHT?
- I DON'T JOKE ABOUT LOVE,
ANDERS.
- [correcting]
ON-DERS.
- I USED TO CUT MYSELF
TO DASHBOARD CONFESSIONAL.
I LOVE LOVE, OKAY?
- UM, HERE'S A JOKE.
WHAT DID THREE GIRLS SAY
TO THE ONE DUDE?
- SO YOU, LIKE, REALLY LOVE HER.
THAT'S COOL.
- EHH, WELL, SHE'S REALLY
THE ONLY CHICK
THAT LETS ME MAKE OUT WITH HER
UNTIL MY TONGUE HURTS.
SHE'S KIND OF MY LAST SHOT
AT LIFELONG HAPPINESS.
WISH ME LUCK.
- ALL RIGHT. DON'T BLOW IT.
[chuckles]
DON'T BLOW IT
LIKE I'M ABOUT TO.
- HEY, BUDDY, I COULDN'T HELP
BUT OVERHEAR
YOU'RE BEING A LITTLE
NERVOUS NELLY FURTADO.
- YEAH, I GUESS.
- YOU NEED A FRIEND?
- OH, NAH.
BLEH! NO. DON'T DO IT.
- BLAKE, TRY IT ONCE, MAN.
LOOK AT ME, MAN.
I GOT IT ALL FIGURED OUT,
BUDDY.
- DID IT CAUSE YOUR EYE
TO DO THAT, OR--
- NO, I WAS BORN WITH THAT.
- OH, OKAY.
THEN, YEAH,
I'LL GIVE IT A SHOT.
- DOESN'T HELP,
I'LL TELL YOU THAT MUCH.
- WHERE ARE MY BEERS?
- OH!
I WAS JUST LOOKING
FOR SOME CRANBERRY JUICE.
- WELL...
LOOK NO FURTHER.
WILL YOU MARRY ME?
- ADAM, ARE YOU--
ARE YOU KIDDING?
I'M 16.
- DEBATABLY THE SEXIEST AGE.
WE DOING THIS OR ARE YOU GONNA
PUSSY OUT ON ME?
CHICKEN.
- ADAM, NO, I--
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT--
- OR, I DON'T KNOW,
YOU CAN KNOCK OFF
ALL THAT GOD STUFF, RIGHT?
AND JUST, PBBBBB...
FUG ME HARD.
- WELL--
- HIT THAT CABOOSE.
- NO, ADAM, MY FAITH MEANS
EVERYTHING TO ME.
- FOREVER?
- I AM NOT HAVING SEX
UNTIL I'M MARRIED.
- YEAH, DUH.
YOU THICK?
YOU DUMB-DUMB.
OBVIOUSLY, THAT'S WHY
I'M PROPOSING TO YOU.
- YOU KNOW WHAT, ADAM,
I THINK WE SHOULD TAKE
SOME TIME OFF.
AND I'LL PRAY FOR YOU.
- YOU'LL BE IN MY PRAYERS.
YOU STILL WANT ME TO CALL YOU
OUT OF CLASS ON TUESDAY?
I'LL TAKE YOU TO SONIC.
WOW, OKAY, YOU GIVE YOUR HEART
TO SOMEONE, RIGHT?
AND THEY JUST RIP IT OUT
AND [bleep]
IN THE HEART CAVITY AREA.
COLLEGE SUCKS.
IT'S STUPID.
- REALLY?
- YEAH.
- I'M HAVING
A REALLY GREAT TIME.
- REALLY?
- OF COURSE,
I'M FROM A BORING SMALL TOWN
WITH ONE STOPLIGHT,
SO THIS IS--THIS IS FUN FOR ME.
- HOW RELIGIOUS ARE YOU?
- I WISH THIS WAS REAL.
[pistol clicks]
[laughter]
HE WOULD HAVE MURDERED HER.
- HEY, IT'S BLAKE, RIGHT?
- OH, [bleep] LOOK AT THIS.
- I SAW YOU ON CAMPUS EARLIER,
AND I'VE GOTTA SAY,
PRETTY CONVINCING
FRENCH POLICE OFFICER.
- THANK YOU.
- HOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE
THE UNDERSTUDY OF JAVERT
IN THIS YEAR'S PRODUCTION
OF LES MIS?
- UNDERSTUDY.
HOW 'BOUT, UH, YOU STUDY
UNDER MY NUT SACK?
- OH!
[laughter]
- RIGHT UNDER THERE.
- THERE IT IS.
- SORRY, IS THAT A NO?
- FRITZ, LIFE...
IS A STAGE.
SMOKE WEED UNTIL YOU DIE.
- THAT'S RIGHT. THAT'S RIGHT.